we've had operation big picture
now welcome to operation open checkbook
sky news has learnt that some of
europe's biggest football clubs
including liverpool and manchester
united
are in talks to join a new competition
that would reshape the sports economic
landscape
a six billion dollar european premier
league assembled by one of the world's
biggest banks
i think there's there are a lot of
dynamics going on in
english and european football right now
uh background of
corona the background of project big
picture
and and now we have another part of the
the wider jigsaw which is probably a
uefa versus
fifa power play crucially it's said to
have the backing of fifa
rather than uefa and that could spark a
civil war between the two governing
bodies
if the champions league is effectively
usurped
the new league would consist of up to 18
teams from across europe
with clubs from italy spain france
germany and england all in negotiations
most of the big six premier league clubs
have been approached about joining the
project
but with up to only five spaces
available to english clubs in the new
league
at least one will miss out
joy beer inside the pogba it's aurier
and it's fun the european premier league
is being hatched even as divisions widen
within english football last week
proposals led by manchester united and
liverpool to reduce the number of
premier league clubs
while funding a bailout of the lower
leagues were attacked by the government
and throughout the game at this moment
in time in the middle of a pandemic when
football is on its knees at so many
different levels
you know the football association is
struggling
uh non-leaguer struggling efl clubs are
struggling the idea that a five billion
pound package is being put together to
set up a new league
it just seems to me another wound for
football
a tournament that further lines the
pockets of football super rich
bankrolled by jp morgan will be an
uncomfortable proposition to many
at a time of economic hardship
substantial payments to the wider sport
may be essential to the european premier
league's political viability
but even then with an american style
model in which relegation hardly
features
it might struggle to gain widespread
public support
the early season premier league table
features the unfamiliar names of everton
and aston villa at its summit in 2016
leicester city became the last rank
outsider to win english football's most
prestigious prize
critics will argue that a widening of
the financial chasm between the premier
league's elite
and the rest will reduce the chances of
ever seeing pictures like these
again mark kleinman sky news